all right welcome to the live stream got
a bunch of new stuff going on today can
never really tell when I'm on but I
think it's now so I'll start I've got a
bunch and you stuff going on I'm sort of
sitting to the side because we have this
new feature where I think I figured out
with stream Labs how to actually put up
the most recent contributions from
people and hopefully it will also show
their messages although now I'm not sure
because these are from last night's
stream and these people had sent
messages via super chat and donation so
maybe it's not actually working I guess
we will see but in any case a lot of
news to talk about I do want to talk
about Donald Trump's just again like
doubling down on the idiocy around
there's good people on both sides with
the neo-nazi rally now kind of with a
linguistic trick saying there's bad
people on both sides but I will I will
get to that momentarily we do now have
stream Labs contributions set up so you
can use stream labs comm slash the David
Pakman show instead of or in addition to
super chat and the advantage of using
stream labs comm slash the david pakman
show is you can still ask questions you
will still see the thank you donation
animation that now plays when super
chats and donations come in at the
bottom of the screen but YouTube doesn't
take their 30% cut from Super chats so
it's an option it's available throughout
I'll be answering questions and on that
note before we get into the politics and
I have so many stories I want to talk
with you about if this is your first
live stream I'm gonna cut right to
number four don't troll pls dont troll
subtle trolling is okay if we don't
notice but please no deliberate trolling
no obvious trolling and hate there our
moderators they will block you they will
ban you it's not a violation of your
free speech rights because we're just a
youtube channel
and if I notice it I'll probably also
block you although there's a lot going
on
use super chat to send in questions or
comments but also you can use stream
labs comm slash the david pakman show
you can still make contributions with
questions and comments that way they
will be read they will be addressed and
it's all it's all fantastic because it
will also circumvent YouTube taking a
cut via the super chat fee and number
three new members and patrons will get
live thank-yous and shout outs
throughout the livestream yesterday we
had a super chat saying they wanted some
kind of targeted Patriot patreon number
let's make it nineteen thirty okay so if
we get to 1930 patrons during the
livestream I will create and release a
huge huge huge membership discount code
and of course everybody will be thanked
and in the meantime if you want to sign
up for membership and not wait for that
discount code you can do so at david
pakman.com slash membership there's a
coupon code already available it is
I voted 17 so let's get into this this
there's so many stories to talk about
but I want to start with the Donald
Trump story related to Charlottesville
okay the I I am sort of confused as to
why Donald Trump is even talking about
this really it seems to me he would be
much better off never mentioning this
again because it was really sort of one
of the biggest and most obvious mistakes
that he made in the reaction to the
Charlottesville debacle which was to say
well listen there are good people very
fine people I think is the way he said
it on both sides and of course the the
two sides being apparently the neo-nazi
white power white supremacist alt
writers and the people who were
demonstrating against racism and
discrimination both sides
I guess according to Trump had very fine
people now that didn't go particularly
well so Trump took major heat from it
and then he was with senator Tim Scott
Republican from South Carolina
african-american and relevant in this
particular case given what it is that
Donald Trump said and
this meeting with Tim Scott Trump comes
out on Air Force One and he says Tim
Scott and I had a great talk I think
especially in light of the advent of
antiphon if you look at what's going on
there you have some pretty bad dudes on
the other side also and essentially
that's what I said now because of what's
happened since then with an toughie when
you look at really what's happened since
Charlottesville a lot of people are
saying and people have actually written
G Trump may have a point now if you're
having trouble parsing the grammar yeah
I don't blame you Trump going on to say
but we had a great conversation
referring to him and Tim Scott and he
has legislation which I actually like
very much the concept of which I support
to get people into certain areas and
building and constructing and putting
people to work I told them yesterday
that's a concept I can support very
easily so what's the main thing here the
main thing is that once again Trump is
talking about an equivalency a false
equivalency I would argue between
neo-nazi protesters who are protesting
in defense of either the you know in
defense of white people or white
identity or protests based on people who
want a white separatism right all
flavors of white supremacy Trump is
saying before it was there's very fine
people on both sides and that didn't go
too well because as soon as you say
there's fine people on both sides you
have to now find and defend specific
neo-nazis as very fine people in order
to make it true so what has Trump done
with these linguistic gymnastics he's
basically flipped it now he's saying
okay there there are bad people on the
side of the neo-nazis but there's bad
people on the side of antiphon so now
all he has to do to make his assertion
true is find one person on the side of
an toughie which would be a pretty bad
person as Trump describes them and now
he has turned basically a completely
deplorable assertion which is defending
neo-nazi protesters as having very fine
people into something where you say well
yeah there are bad people on
both sides and people asking why am I
not titling the video good people on
both sides good people on both sides is
what Trump said a very long time ago
right now Trump is saying something else
and in effect I think it's actually it
makes the original statement even more
absurd which is well there's bad people
on both sides and it's probably a false
equivalency that is going to work much
more effectively to convince people that
Trump really isn't saying anything wrong
so it is is absolutely and stunning to
me that Trump is even still talking
about this but he is and and seemingly
in the midst of talking about putting
people to work and his meeting with Tim
Scott he brings up that there's bad
people on both sides after all
full stop period I don't know I
genuinely don't know what Trump's
understanding is of the situation at
this point but this is a topic that he
should stay away from and again give me
the list of the very fine neo-nazis I
want the list of the people who are on
the side of the neo-nazis and the white
supremacists and the white separatists
and and whatever the KKK etc give me the
names of the people that are really fine
people and let's talk to them and see
whether their views would be qualified
as really fine people by anybody with
any common sense I it's absolutely
bewildering to me absolutely and totally
bewildering to me and we'll we'll
continue to see what what happens with
that and I don't get why Trump is
continuing to talk about it at this
point okay
other news breaking in the last few
hours North Korea has reportedly fired a
missile that has flown over Japan and
landed in the sea this is as of just a
few minutes ago still an unidentified
missile I suppose in terms of the size
scope and capabilities of it and this is
following the test of an alleged
hydrogen bomb earlier this month I'm
increasingly interested in what some are
considering an unconventional view on
the North Korea nuclear weapons
development thing I actually think
that it would be interesting to consider
and there are some geopolitics experts
and some foreign policy experts who have
been reading lately who seem to think
this is an interesting idea what about
going to North Korea as if they are
adults and of course when you've got Kim
jong-un it's hard to imagine any of
those individuals being able to act like
adults but let's let's at least try to
treat them like adults go to North Korea
and say listen we understand why you
want to do nuclear weapons research and
development if you have any
understanding of geopolitical history we
sort of have instances of what happens
when countries publicly give up nuclear
weapons programs and it doesn't always
go super well for them in terms of
geopolitical positioning and then we
have examples of countries that have
that have retained or developed nuclear
weapons and they seem to have a better
time so we get why it is given your
circumstances why you would want to
develop nuclear weapons here's what we
would be willing to do as the
international as an international
agreement of sorts we will allow North
Korea to do research to have a nuclear
program but it will have limits very
specific limits and North Korea has to
abide by whatever requirements are
established as part of that agreement
and that would include allowing
inspectors to go in that would include
parameters which would make evidence
that they cannot develop nuclear
capabilities beyond a certain point that
has not been agreed upon by the
international diplomatic community and
see what they do because I think that
it's possible I think it's possible that
this might actually deescalate and is
that I know that there will be trolls
who will say David are you suggesting
new clearly arming North Korea no that's
not what I'm suggesting what I am
suggesting is considering that part of
North Korea's continued belligerents
might be the way that they are treated
on the international stage not
deservedly right not undeservedly and
that since otherwise let's take a step
back what are the other ways that North
Korea might be stopped in its
belligerence well if the food aid
requirements get even more dire then
it's possible that this routine of Sen
agreeing to send food aid in exchange
for them claiming to stop the missiles
the threats whatever right it might work
but otherwise to really turn around the
situation in North Korea there's going
to need to be either even more extreme
sanctioning which is going to be a
disaster for the citizens of North Korea
or there's going to need to be military
action which whatever you think about
military action in the abstract and and
specifically in this particular
situation it will lead to significant
civilian casualties if it's going to be
anything even remotely serious so what
I'm suggesting is let's consider for a
moment that we still have those options
what if there was an attempt to actually
talk to North Korea as if they they are
adults and rationale which they're not
right which they're not I understand
that and I I don't know I'd be
interested in seeing what people's
thoughts are about that let's block a
couple people who are just doing obvious
very very obvious trolling and like I
said if you're gonna do the trolling
it's got to be subtle it's got to be
subtle and right now there's pretty
obvious trolling going on okay before I
jump into some of the other news I will
restate we're on a live stream these are
live unless that's a replay super chat
is on that's the dollar sign at the
bottom of the chat window you can use
that to send questions and comments you
can also go to stream labs.com slash the
David Pakman show no matter which of the
two you do when you make a contribution
it will trigger a very clever animation
you will be thanked on screen and then
your name will pop up up here as a
recent donor which I find to be very
cool all right so you can do that Stream
Labs comm slash the david pakman show
circumvent youtube's $30 I'm sorry there
percent super chat fee but by all means
feel free to use the regular super chat
and there we have an example dum dum dum
dum dum has made a $5 contribution
through super chat and now they are
showing up up here in this list and for
whatever reason there I wish that their
actual comments stayed up here because
that would allow me to just read it off
of there but I guess I will have to look
at it in the chat window and the comment
is of course watch your vids on YouTube
when they're up and this is a thanks
thanks for the content my pleasure my
pleasure and we are hoping to continue
expanding the amount of content that we
are doing also new members and patrons
during the stream will get live
shoutouts and thank-yous from me summer
forthcoming we've already received a
number of new membership sign up just
while we've been chatting here and I
will do a bunch of thank-yous all
together all together in a little bit
okay few other stories that I want to
touch on there's a very interesting New
York Times article that has been
released today and I want to thank
Christina who donated $1 and I will get
to Christina's question comment
momentarily but Trump humiliated Jeff
Sessions after Moeller appointment it's
an article by Michael Schmidt and Maggie
Haberman from just a couple hours ago in
The New York Times and it indicates and
thanks to TDPS Goldmember who has made a
$2 contribution appreciate that shortly
after learning in May that special cat
that a special counsel had been
appointed to investigate links between
his campaign associates in Russia
President Trump berated Attorney General
Jeff Sessions in an oval office meeting
and said he should resign according to
current and former administration
officials and others briefed on the
matter now of course immediately
Trumpets committed ideological Trump is
said fake news there's no way Maggie
Haberman and Michael Schmitt could know
that think about it for a second think
about the timing and think about the
escalated tensions that we saw between
Donald Trump and Jeff Sessions that
coincided exactly with this time this is
what people don't get
about the Trump rumors and the Trump
reporting and the Trump Russia blackmail
dossier by former mi6 operative
Christopher Steele there are as yet
unproven assertions that have been made
but what's been definitively debunked so
far I have a hard time thinking of
anything and over time we did a really
good story it was I believe late last
week or maybe earlier this week
indicating that every week more and more
of that supposedly totally fake Russia
blackmail file is confirmed as true the
Michael Cohen stuff the Trump business
in Russia stuff it's getting to the
point where everything but Trump having
a urine fetish involving living it out
with Russian prostitutes is being
confirmed so I think it's really
important for people to consider that
over time more and more of these
assertions end up being verified and the
assertion being made by this New York
Times article from today which I'm
talking about Trump humiliated Jeff
sessions after Moeller appointment it
coincides with Trump's statements that
had he known that Jeff Sessions was
going to recuse himself from anything
Russia related he wouldn't have selected
him everything else that Trump has said
publicly it all aligns with exactly what
is being reported in The New York Times
by Michael Schmidt and Maggie Haberman
absolutely 100% and I every once in a
while I don't even like to mention the
existence of this subreddit but it
exists right so I'll mention it I'll
check out what's going on on the Donald
the underscore Donald subreddit and its
total cognitive dissonance and absolute
irrational denial absolute I mean any
almost anything that comes out of the
New York Times and Washington Post it's
fake it's distorted it's a hit piece it
can't be trusted and within days weeks
or sometimes months almost every aspect
of it is proven to be true really really
just stunning disconnection from reality
over there really really bizarre
okay let me deal with a couple of the
contributions that have been made here
Christina sent a dollar contribution
through stream labs.com slash the david
pakman show saying do you have to tidy
up your living room before the live
streams or do you typically keep your
surroundings tidy also in your opinion
is society as we know it collapsing no I
don't think society is collapsing this
is not my living room and I don't tidy
up this is just how it is all the time
I've got you know my drum practice pad
over here I have my most recent piece of
art which it's not that recent because I
haven't been painting there's really
nothing on the couch other than my my
messenger bag this is how it is all the
time so fortunately I don't really have
to do any tidying up TDPS Goldmember has
sent a $2 contribution through stream
labs comm slash the david pakman show
saying this comment can only be read by
other owners of the David Pakman show
bolt membership package very very clever
absolutely and incredibly clever I love
that and thanks to everybody who's been
contributing at stream labs.com
slash the david pakman show I am going
to do new member Thank You shorty we are
trying to sort of put together two
thousand donors through patreon.com
slash david pakman show the barrier to
entry is very very low a dollar
contribution will put you up on the
scoreboard at patreon.com slash david
pakman showed the reason we're doing
that of course is because of the youtube
demonetized e monetization crisis you
know what's super depressing and and I
will do patreon thank-yous and
membership thank you shortly when
YouTube ad pocalypse began on March 31st
of 2017 I was sort of hoping it was all
a temporary glitch we've since learned
that YouTube D monetization is
effectively permanent so programs like
mine and others we have to look for
other sources of revenue at this point
to sort of stay even with where we were
before March 31st
Facebook now has rolled out similar sort
of ad limitation guidelines that are
very similar very similar to what we are
seeing on YouTube in terms of
restricting ads to certain types of
content and it's stunning to me I was
reading through the Facebook ad
restrictions today and there's a line a
bullet item there's sort of like a
series of bullets about what types of
content on YouTube on Facebook rather
both video and written would not be
viable for monetization any social issue
that is debatable is subject to D
monetization on Facebook now this
doesn't affect us because we're not even
part of you to of Facebook monetization
yet in other words Facebook monetization
for video content is in beta still and I
was hoping that soon we would be able to
participate before we are even allowed
into Facebook monetization to try to
make money from the posting of our video
content to Facebook they've already
restricted monetization on what
effectively is 99% of the content we do
do we do any content that doesn't deal
with social or economic or other issues
that are debatable what's not debatable
at this point in time it's it's a dark
moment it really is a dark moment for
independent media and live me of you
know progressive media media that is not
legacy media and the saddest thing about
it for me is that there was this period
where it really looked like we were
going to see just such a flourishing of
programs like the David Pakman show and
in there multiple iterations I would say
between really between November 2016 and
March 2017 and I think part of it was
the election of Donald Trump for sure
which has engaged many new people in
politics that were not engaged before
part of it was the 2016 election cycle
really saw the legitimacy of online and
in depend
Media as a means of reaching viewers for
advertisers it really became much more
legitimate and it was so on the up and
up and then when March 31st hit and
March 31st on this graph is indicated by
the number two as you can see there's
been barely any recovery other than this
brief period a few months ago when that
hit period number two it was just
depressing
I mean I don't really know any other way
to say it just totally depressing
because it really turned around the
direction that online media was was very
strongly headed in okay on that note let
me do a few membership thank-yous
because we have had people signing up
while I've been chatting here membership
gets you access to the bonus show as
well as the commercial free access pass
was a coupon code available that coupon
code is I voted 17 Chester misuk Chester
misuk has signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership opting not to use the
coupon code thank you so much Sean Nolan
has signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership William Hughes is now
officially a david pakman show member
after signing up and matthew blanchard
has also signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership and for that i'm very
very grateful thanks to everybody who
has signed up just while we have been
talking here I will also do just one
quick patreon thank you and then we'll
get back to the politics David Travis
has made a $2.00 contribution at
patreon.com slash david pakman show we
started the evening at 1918 patrons we
are now at 1919 patrons and the
challenge number for tonight that I've
offered is 1930 okay if we get to 1930
patrons tonight I will create and
announce just to you a 55% discount code
off of membership okay
1930 is the target that we are looking
for there okay all right let me deal
with a couple other stories that have
popped up in the last
couple of hours that may not be stories
that make it onto the broadcast show but
I think are still interesting stories
I've told you before that there are a
portion of Republicans who blame
President Obama for his response to
Hurricane Katrina now of course if you
generally understand time to sort of
move in a forward direction as most of
us do for sort of practical purposes for
living everyday life you would know that
Barack Obama was not President of the
United States during Hurricane Katrina
that it was of course george w bush who
was responsible for the bogus and
terrible response to Hurricane Katrina
Donald Trump tried to take a shot at
President Obama for not coming to
Florida after the last major hurricane
had hit and of course the problem with
that is the the last major hurricane to
hit Florida happened four years before
Barack Obama took office
Alex Wayne of Bloomberg tweeted the
exchange a Trump supporter in Florida
said where was Obama after the last
hurricane Trump says tell them and
gestures to reporters and of course the
last hurricane to hit Florida was
Hurricane Wilma in 2005 and you know
it's this is one of those small things
but it's again just evidence of the
total disconnect that exists between
Donald Trump and the facts and also
between his supporters and the facts
because what do you think that supporter
was hoping for right what do you think
that that supporter was hoping to get do
you think he was hoping to hear from
Donald Trump oh no no no
President Obama was actually not
president when the last major hurricane
hit Florida now you heard tell the media
because they won't report on it just
absolutely and utterly pathetic
thanks to sherry who has sent a dollar
super cheque and thanks to waiting to
fade who has sent a $2 Super chat let me
take a look through some of the non
super chat comments in the chat I I do
like to answer a variety
of questions not just people who are
making contributions on stream labs comm
slash david pakman show or via super
chat au student 2018 said by the way I
just joined the live stream what did I
miss so far I would recommend going back
and looking at the live stream from the
beginning au student also saying isn't
this the second or third live stream
this week if so this will definitely get
more people to support the show fans
love it when hosts always interact with
the audience is there anything Obama
isn't blamed for not really not really
he's blamed blame for most things what
else do we have here
will you ever watch video or Vimeo I
don't know if that's to me maybe you
mean will be beyond those platforms I'm
absolutely open to it
Miranda Philippines said David I love
your live chats but it's 3:20 a.m. in
Europe you are keeping me from my beauty
sleep so I'll watch the rest of the
stream tomorrow yeah that's very very
late that is incredibly late and I don't
don't blame you for jumping off of the
stream
let's see people angry about the
Facebook censorship it's not really
censorship it's just the monetization go
BC says that I'm refusing to comment on
the several voicemails that they've left
over the past month we do get about 50
voicemails a day and we use one a day so
we can't always address every question
or comment also you'll notice most
voicemails that get played are between
40 and 120 I'm sorry 40 and 90 seconds
long so for the people who leave me
three four five or even six or sometimes
more full three-minute voicemails that's
the limit on our Google Voice number
there's probably a reason those aren't
getting played and it's the the length
the duration
let's see Tina Flintstone set flint
stone says is there a David Pakman store
to support the show yes david pakman.com
slash gear and also is there a place
where i can find all of the ways to
contribute and support the David Pakman
show
well the three major ones are right here
membership which is david pakman.com
slash membership
patreon which is patreon.com slash david
pakman show and amazon if you ever shop
on amazon david pakman.com slash amazon
before you shop and that will send us a
kickback of about seven percent okay for
everything you buy which is very very
exciting let's see what other questions
we've got here david pakman and michael
brooks need to form a rap band yeah I'm
not much for wrapping but I do play
drums so I could maybe lay down a beat
in the background David is that a
sideways Belgian flag no that's a
landscape that I painted but yeah it's
not it's not particularly good
someone's suggesting I put a painting on
the wall I've got a huge painting right
there is the art Napoleon ice cream it
is not what other questions do we have
here do you know if David will ever read
the top YouTube comments this is a good
question we get about 1,200 to 1,500
YouTube comments per day so of course
it's not possible for me to read every
single one of those comments but I do
look at a sampling of comments on
YouTube I'll try to look at a few
comments on every video and then also
respond to a few comments so yeah I've
got a sense people wonder do I know if a
video gets major dislikes or do I do I
know if a video is getting a ton of
comments or angry comments or whatever I
do I do know I am intimately familiar
with which videos are doing well with
which videos are not doing well and all
of that stuff okay
there's a bunch of other stuff that's
going on here so let's see if I can if I
can get caught up on that first and
foremost let's see if we have I think we
had a couple of stream labs donations
come in okay Spanish tongue twister sent
a $5 stream Labs comment through stream
labs comm slash David Pakman show
I assume Spanish tongue twister is
actually claw earth one two three four
who loves the Spanish tongue twisters
I'll do my best with this one let's see
one two one two whoa you do book it
through
alarum beer a pirate recupera girl -
okay - whoa - okay comprehend - while I
- okay - whoa okay so basically what
this means is that one had a tube and
the tube he had broke and to recover the
tube he was forced to buy a tube that
was identical to the tube that he had
now it's not a tongue twister in English
because tube and had are very different
words in English but in Spanish do Bo
and Dougal are the same and that's why
these these livestreams are something
else that's why that's a tongue twister
Cristina sent a dollar contribution
through stream labs.com slash David
Pakman show what temperature do you like
to keep the temperature set to during
the winter months a very good question
so generally speaking at david pakman
show studios I like to keep the
temperature pretty cool because number
one we need to turn off HVAC while we're
actually broadcasting recording the show
because it's quite loud and that applies
to both heat and cold so during the
summer I'll try to cool it down as much
as possible like - 68 or 69 degrees so
that then during the time we're
recording it won't go up by more than
you know 4 maybe 5 degrees on the
warmest days I don't want to be fixing
on camera you know and during the winter
we'll sort of do the very similar thing
you think well during the winter I
should really heat it up so that then
it'll cool down but not too much while
we're recording but no it always gets
warm because of all the equipment we
have in the room so even during the
during the winter we'll keep the the
studio at about 70 my home I will set
the air conditioner typically to 72 for
the overnight and that gets down in my
bedroom to about 69 degrees because
that's where I don't know all the cold
goes into the bedroom and during the
winter I will set the temperature to
actually 66 during the night I do not
like warm temperatures during the night
so yeah 66 or 67 degrees during the
night and again out maybe 69
during the day I'm not a fan of
incredibly warm temperatures anywhere
that I am de Nord sent the $5
contribution through stream labs at
stream labs.com / the David Pakman show
saying thanks for providing unbiased
information something the network's
won't do i appreciate the contribution
and i appreciate the comment but i want
to be this is something I'm working on
with many of my students in the Boston
College class that I am teaching the
term bias applies differently to opinion
programming and I do opinion programming
so there's certainly significant bias in
my broadcast in the sense that it is a
progressive program but I try to be
objective and avoid this sort of faux
neutrality right that I have no interest
in at all fashion advice has sent a
$2.00 contribution through stream labs
comm slash the david pakman show can we
get shirts hoodies and jumpers with the
repeating david pakman show logo like
this and they're sending a link let me
take a look at that let's see what those
look like interesting a repeating logo
all over I will look into that I will
look into that let me make a note for my
to do list tomorrow which fortunately is
only about 45 different items in
addition to getting caught up with email
repeating hoodie t-shirts I will look
into that for you okay let me just paste
that link that you sent the Bart Simpson
shirts just so I can get get an answer
on that all right I will look into it
tomorrow and hopefully get an answer for
you and then now let's take a look at
the super chats which are also
continuing to come in where did I leave
off let's start with Dylan collet dylan
collet sent a $5 super chat saying
thoughts on Steve Bannon asserting that
President Trump triggers the left and
they can't handle it rationally in his
interview with Charlie Rose I don't I
mean listen the term trigger has become
very very I don't know stigmatized
and whether it's that Trump triggers the
left or Trump infuriates the left or
Trump does whatever to the left
Donald Trump is a totally incompetent
politician whose philosophy is only self
aggrandizement and greed and self
enrichment for him and his family right
so I think it's perfectly reasonable
that the left or really anybody who's
paying attention including former
Trumpets who have bailed right we still
have the ideologically committed
trumpets very very strongly on board but
there are trumpets who have bailed as
evidenced by the the decreased approval
ratings I think Trump should be
triggering everyone for lack of a better
term George sent a $2 super chat can Jeb
still fix it or are things too far gone
I don't think that Jeb is going to be
fixing anything anytime soon although
I'll just hold on a second we just had
we had a very very CUTE roll oh and
Lauren already took care of them yeah
thanks Lauren we just all of a sudden
these trolls just pop out of nowhere and
it is like turbo trolling in the
comments and I just have no interest in
it whatsoever i I think Jeb's not going
to be fixing anything anytime soon all
right
actual justice warrior has sent the $10
super chat thanks very much actual
justice warrior says unite write were
all leftist libertarians Jason Kessler
Doc's showed he organized with Obama and
Occupy Wall Street Jewish girlfriend
Mike Enoch
doxxed family friend of Clintons and
Jewish girlfriend are Spencer supports
Bernie and are all socialists brilliant
absolutely brilliant and ten out of ten
parody of ten out of two couldn't
couldn't have said it better myself
thank you I hope that was worth 10 bucks
Darryl Dudley I really hope that was
fake by the way because that was a that
was next
that was some that was next level Darryl
Dudley has sent a $5 super chat
what's the Russian playbook that you
talked about in the past that talks
about how strategy against countries for
America they talk racial racial divide
yeah let me see Russian I forget the
name of it geopolitics book let's see if
that comes up I will notice it right
away oh it's so it's the foundations of
geopolitics by Alexander Dugan if you're
going to buy it buy it through our
amazon link david pakman.com slash
amazon it's from 97 and some of those
foundations of geopolitics that Barrels
referring to are the idea that russia
has an interest in basically causing
chaos all over the world the impetus of
that being to destabilize to present a
comparatively stable and rational Russia
to enable Russia to have a stronger
place geopolitically at all negotiating
tables so to speak it's a very
interesting book I've only read excerpts
and I would like to at some point read
the entire thing start to finish in the
unites the key part the book emphasizes
that Russia must spread anti-americanism
everywhere the main scapegoat will be
precisely the u.s. in the United States
Russia should use its special services
within the borders of the United States
hello to fuel instability and separatism
for instance provoke afro-american
racists Russia should introduce
geopolitical disorder into internal
American activity messing with an
election will do that encouraging all
kinds of separatism and ethnic social
and racial conflicts actual actively
supporting all dissident movements
extremist racist and sectarian groups
thus destabilizing internal political
processes in the US it would also make
sense simultaneously to support
isolationist tendencies in American
politics very interesting very
interesting when you consider what it is
that Russia has been doing a very
interesting book I recommend it despite
not having read the entire thing very
very interesting and thanks to Dudley
Darryl Dudley for the $5 thank you super
chat any ghost has sent a twenty dollar
super chat I think it's fair now at this
point to call any
goes to super chat all-star right I mean
why not D monetization being about
keeping YouTube and Facebook
family-friendly is ridiculous on its
face it's all about maintaining Oleg
ARCIC control over the narratives that
people are exposed to YouTube isn't
YouTube anymore it's Google Tube I read
something interesting on Facebook today
about YouTube D monetization which was
it was admittedly somewhat
conspiratorial but the concept was if
YouTube really wanted to push YouTube
red which is their subscription service
for $10 a month
what if they demonetised
which would cause channels like mine to
have to talk about how we're not making
money from ad revenue and thus people
might sign up for YouTube red to support
those channels seems a little bit seems
a little bit more complex than necessary
right I think that there's a number of
other sort of cases that could be made
but it's an it's an interesting idea I
think the bigger picture of there being
sort of ulterior motives for this de
monetization and clampdown on on
advertising on so-called controversial
content which apparently is almost
anything now I think that there's
something to that okay let's see
somebody asking there are bad people on
both sides how is that controversial
yeah you missed the beginning of the
stream and I encourage you to go back to
the beginning and check it out the whole
idea is that Trump is doing a linguistic
game with all of us where at first he
said well there are really fine people
on both sides including the side of the
neo-nazis and people were rightly
outraged saying wait a second can you
point to some of those really great
people find people on the side of the
neo-nazis so Trump brought this up again
on Air Force One today and his new thing
is there are really bad people on both
sides and that is
much more it's it's a it's a joke
because to be true he's still drawing a
false equivalency between the neo-nazi
protesters and the counter neo-nazi
protesters but now he's basically saying
if you can find a single bad person
on the side of an - fuh for example then
he's vindicated even though the reality
is that it's a total false equivalency
so that that was sort of the point of it
that was pious Malta who mentioned that
the Prophet said David you could be
taken more seriously if you put your
hair into giant Liberty spikes it's
funny you mentioned that because I have
announced that if and when we get to
2,000 patreon contributors I'll do an
entire broadcast show with my hair like
this
thanks to christina by the way I'll do
an entire broadcast show with my hair
like this from the studio and when I
posted this to my Instagram account
people went crazy people were so
overcome with emotion some of them
almost considered setting fire to their
own houses and vehicles I so this is not
exactly spikes but it is certainly a
different look and that requires merely
getting to 2,000 patreon contributors
we're at 1919 right now I mentioned
earlier in the livestream that if we get
to 1930 patrons tonight by the end of
the stream we've got about a half hour
left that I will create and release a
fifty five percent discount code that
everybody can use to sign up for
membership and all you have to do is
make a contribution of any amount and
calm slash david pakman show link is in
the description you can also get
questions asked and answered through
both super chat which is the dollar sign
at the bottom of the chat window or
through stream labs.com slash the david
pakman show and if you use the stream
labs option stream labs.com slash the
david pakman show you will be a
circumventing the 30% cut from super
chat that YouTube does take okay so
that's just a little something
a little something to keep in mind that
you might like you might not like people
are telling me that it's a great great
thing Cristina has sent a contribution
through stream labs comm slash the David
Pakman show thanks for taking my
questions I have watched the show for a
long time and really enjoy asking random
questions and getting to know more about
you also is that tap water you're
drinking or do you have a filtration
system it is indeed tap water but it is
filtered tap water filtered tap water I
have a Brita and I'm actually seeing
some particles inside so I don't know if
that's something I should be worried
about but really it's truly delicious
water truly truly delicious water that
we have here in Boston so that that I
think is something that you know we
could say a lot of things about Boston
but one of the good things we can say is
we have really really good Seltzer here
okay all right let me just briefly tell
you a few other stories if you're just
joining us now we've already talked
about Donald Trump's recent comments
once again about Charlottesville on Air
Force one today we've talked about North
Korea launching another missile
according to reports that went over
Japan and into the sea I gave an idea
for an alternative way of maybe dealing
with North Korea when it comes to
weapons we've also talked about a new
report in The New York Times that Donald
Trump reportedly humiliated Jeff
sessions after robert muller was
appointed special counsel which makes
absolute total and perfect sense and
i've also talked about this bizarre
slamming of barack obama by donald trump
because Obama didn't visit Florida
during the last hurricane that hit
Florida which of course was three years
before he was elected which is sort of a
bizarre thing bizarre thing to criticize
President Obama for couple other things
that I want to mention Bernie Sanders
has been doing some really really
interesting stuff sort of surrounding
the release of his Medicare for all bill
now if you did miss my analysis of
Bernie's Medicare for all bill please
check out
what should you check out well today's
program right I mean we have a YouTube
clip up about it where we go in detail
into Bernie's plan and how it would be
paid for and everything else but there
is there's now a series of videos that
Bernie Sanders has asked for from people
who live in countries with universal
health care to share their experiences
with it and there's some really really
interesting stuff now if you've been
following the healthcare systems of
other countries the way we have on the
program for a very very long time you
would not really be surprised by what
we're hearing from people who live in
countries with universal healthcare but
it is still very very interesting to see
I also want to mention what is the other
story that I had I had a bunch of
different oh there's a really strange
story and this might be just the stuff
of debunk Abul conspiracy theories but
I've now seen a few articles about how
there are a number of diplomats that
have been working in Cuba that have
suffered what are being described as
sort of weird ailments including brain
injuries affecting hearing and speech
which is a really really odd thing and I
want to research that more tomorrow and
see if it's if it's it won't be on
tomorrow's program but we'll see if
maybe it makes the show next week really
strange and also there's a new report on
common dreams that confirms to us that
we're seeing even more concentration of
wealth around the world there are now
five men and they are all men I don't
mean five people five men who own as
much wealth as the bottom 50% of the
world's population right so about seven
what's the population now 2017 earth
population you've got to be approaching
eight billion right 7.5 billion in April
of 2017 so you've got three and
three-quarters billion people and then
you've got five dudes and they share
rather they have the same amount of
wealth the 3.75 billion people as those
five people and this is not you know you
can make you can make moral arguments
foots falling asleep I have to adjust
excuse me you can make moral arguments
about why that level of inequality is
bad I tend to think that when it's the
right that has to be convinced of
something it's better not to use the
types of arguments that appeal to the
left use arguments that should appeal to
the right it's bad economically it's bad
for law and order that level of
inequality it's bad for well I guess
it's part of law and order but it's bad
for crime it's bad in endless ways and
there are right-wingers who will never
be rich but who are committed to the
idea that this level of inequality and
the ease with which inequality has just
been growing and growing and growing is
sort of inherently American or
inherently patriotic or inherently part
of any capitalist system and the truth
is it's not right I don't consider
myself a socialist nor a communist or a
Marxist of anything like that I consider
myself someone who supports social
democracy a well-regulated capitalist
system that works to provide a basic
standard of living for everybody pool
resources through taxation for some
basic benefits that I believe should be
rights but still allow the innovation
and just innovation I don't think I have
to add another another word the
innovation and entrepreneurial spirit
that is encouraged by capitalism in some
sense but without letting it get out of
control right reining it in that's
that's not an anti-capitalist
perspective and those on the right who
believe that if you think inequality is
a problem you must not be a capitalist I
reject that at its face I reject that at
its face and you know if more people had
education in economics I think that that
would be useful but the thing is
education and economics won't make you
empathize right that that comes from
somewhere else okay let's look at some
of these other super chats here debark
oh for have sent a $5 super chat
Sam cedar reports that Dave Rubin
secretly cut a sponsorship deal with the
Koch brothers in exchange for
interviewing certain guests let me see
how Sam titled that let's see if that's
actually Sam cedar I'd be interested if
that's actually how Sam titled the clip
just emailing with Sam yesterday we're
gonna see each other in almost a month
to the day at a conference I'm not
seeing that video on Sam's channel maybe
it was not uploaded as an individual
clip yet mm-hmm let's see if I search
for Reuben maybe if that will come up ah
one day ago of course Dave Rubin is
propped up by the Koch brothers so
listen my understanding is I have no
horse in the race my understanding is
that Dave Rubin does have a sponsorship
type deal with some kind of
libertarian-leaning organization and the
assertion is that that organization is
funded in part by the Koch brothers so
it would be an indirect funding by the
Koch brothers but it would still be I
don't know the facts of it I don't know
the facts of it but I think that that
that's I mean hey if that's the truth
that would be something to be very aware
of when you're watching Dave Reubens
show Chris Harris has sent a $10 super
chat Russia World Cup 2018 how do you
think Russia will receive the world LGBT
and race Plus Trump administration
reaction I'm not sure what you mean by
trump administration reaction I am
really sort of distraught over the next
two World Cups in Russia and in Qatar as
many of you know I'm from Argentina and
in fact this this I'm I know that this
might become some kind of animated image
but let me see if I can ground I
actually have my little Argentinian flag
on my desk here what does this look like
on camera here it is and when I'm
preparing the show that sometimes will
wave in the wind why there's wind
indoors I don't really know but there
did whenever I look at the flag it's
waving in the wind and credit
yeah I'm from Argentina so of course I
follow soccer pretty closely and I
followed the Argentinean men's national
team and I absolutely love the World Cup
and I've been very conflicted about the
World Cup for years because FIFA is is
just rife with corruption there are
commonly there is sort of oppression of
poor people in the area around the event
locations in Qatar in particular you've
got just a totally corrupt situation
that even led to the World Cup being
held there in 2022
you've got effectively slaves building
the facilities for the World Cup
it is absolutely horrible and yet and
I've interviewed Dave Zirin about this
almost a Dave Reuben I've interviewed
Dave Zirin about this and he says you
know just watching the games is not
immoral but you should be advocating for
change and trying to change the
circumstances that are impacting these
events and and I'm conflicted because if
the ratings continue to be good that's
not really going to stimulate any change
you know so that's that's a tough thing
but yeah I'm curious to see what
ultimately happens in Russia with the
World Cup okay donations and super chats
continue to come in do people like this
by the way this thing up here that sort
of gives us a running count of what who
the latest contributors are I'm kind of
liking it I must say let's see who else
is who's next here there's a $2 message
that was retracted there's 280z turbo
280z turbo has sent a $5 super chat have
the behavioral economic effects of
single-payer been studied people may be
more willing to take a risk on a new job
well if insurance is guaranteed yeah
I've talked about this before you are
going to have a much more efficient
labor market you were going to have more
committed employees if people have to
stay in a job to avoid losing affordable
health care for themselves and/or their
families that's going to lead to less I
deal matches between employers and
employees and one of the I recently read
Tyler Cowens book and interviewed him
about it let me see what the name of
that book is just so I can recommend it
to you because it talks about matching
the complacent class and one of the
things that Tyler Cowen economist Tyler
Cowen talks about in his book the
complete complacent class is that modern
technology allows us to have matching
that is very very good and by matching
it means you can basically not go to a
restaurant that you don't that you're
not going to like because you know what
to look for in reviews you know what to
look for in descriptions and you can
avoid going to restaurants you don't
like so like if you look at my Yelp
reviews they are very heavily skewed to
four and five stars because I'm able to
match myself with restaurants that I am
very likely to enjoy in the same way all
of the new ways in which hiring is done
whether it's recruiters and headhunters
or online application job alerts
whatever that allows much better
matching between candidates and jobs and
if you were to eliminate this issue of
having to stick out a job or even take a
job because of the healthcare benefits
that it provides you're going to
[Music]
significantly improve the mental health
of people you're going to reduce
employee turnover you're going to
increase productivity no doubt
whatsoever so I think that's a really
interesting one 280z turbo Himalayan
rock salt has sent a five australian
dollar super chat one argument against
universal health care is that the
defense budget in the US needs to be
prioritized what are your thoughts on
this I mean listen the defense budget is
the number one priority anytime a budget
has passed look at how much we spend on
defense and just consider a couple
different things number one we have
dozens of bases in Germany military
bases in Germany would we be just as
safe if we had a few fewer bases in
Germany I would say that we are I think
that the defense budget
is incredibly bloated but I want to say
something else you don't need to touch
the defense budget to do universal
health care consider the mathematics of
it look at Gerald Friedman from the
University of Massachusetts Amherst I've
interviewed him about it
look at his analyses of what universal
health care would cost you don't have to
touch defense if that's really your
concern and I think that that's
something that is a misconception truly
a misconception okay very quickly let me
do a couple of different thank-yous and
and different things that are going on
patreon.com slash david pakman show I am
asking for your support through patreon
so that we continue doing what we do and
ideally growing what we do we have
exciting things planned but we can't do
it in the wake of YouTube D monetization
unless we grow our base of support I do
want to thank Chris Templin who has made
a $2 a month pledge through patreon.com
slash David Pakman show we're trying to
get to 2,000 patrons that's our
immediate and short-term goal and
ultimately I'd like to get to 3,000
patients now on the membership side you
can also become a member at david
pakman.com slash membership i want to
thank I reincarnate and Wong all of whom
have signed up during the live stream at
david pakman.com slash membership it's a
beautiful thing truly a beautiful thing
and I want to thank everybody who has
been contributing in that way and let me
now go to a few of your contributions at
stream lab stream labs comm slash the
david pakman show allows for what it
allows for people to make contributions
without giving 30% of it to youtube
which is what youtube takes for super
chat's purple haze o9 has made a $5
contribution david unfortunately i
cannot afford a subscription as i just
moved and need to pay the rent but i
appreciate what you do please keep it up
best of luck well thank you I really
appreciate that I
appreciate your support and I actually
have a very interesting email I won't I
could read it now I'm not going to
because I want to save it for next week
but I told a story last week on the show
about how once I received an email from
a guy roughly my age who said David I
like your show I support what you do
ideologically but I'm not going to make
a financial contribution because you are
a bachelor and I am married with a
family and three kids and I don't want
to take my hard-earned money and support
your bachelor lifestyle to which I said
that's absolutely fine although I decide
whether to support causes based on
whether I think they are worth
supporting rather than the marital
status of the recipient it was sort of
but just a funny thing and I got an
email from someone who said hey I that
made me contribute and she wrote a very
very interesting letter to me that I
will be reading on the program next week
okay and I think that I think that
you're gonna like it I think you're
gonna find it very very interesting and
sort of endearing right I think it's
it's a pretty pretty interesting letter
I got okay
Himalayan rock salt has Oh Himalayan
rock salt repeated the same five
Australian dollar super chat maybe
that's a glitch Toni Merritt has sent a
ten British pound super chat do you
think Roger stones recent comments about
how removing Trump would cause a civil
war and that those who vote to remove
him should fear for their lives are
possibly criminal he's truly vile I
think that they are possibly criminal
although he's not going to be prosecuted
unless something changes significantly
significantly within the sort of
political crime avoidance complex I
don't even know what to call it but I
don't think it is likely that we are
going to see that it is absolutely
disgusting comment I mean it's if we're
talking about mafioso style commentary
right hunter Ragland has sent a ten
dollar super chat David what are your
thoughts on Sam Harris Christopher
Hitchens and Richard Dawkins three of my
favorite public intellectuals also what
are your thoughts on New Atheism
you know my views on those three people
and on new eighth
are like many things that I look into
nuanced and not one-sided I am NOT on
the contingent of the left that believes
particularly sam harris but the others
as well are just vile and disgusting
people I think that there are a lot of
very interesting and well-thought-out
ideas that have come from Harris
Hitchens and Dawkins I also think that
in some areas it's not so much that
they're wrong but they lack context or
they are sort of disproportionately
focused on certain issues I guess I
would say but I am NOT a hater of those
three new atheism I think is a fine
movement to the extent that it doesn't
start bordering on the the type of more
indiscriminate sort of xenophobia and
isms that can be problematic but I don't
think anybody is going to agree on my
views about new atheism and those three
because I really see both the good and
the concerning about about all of it
Chris Harris has sent a five-dollar
super chat our right-wing libertarians
really anarcho-capitalists promoting
promoting new-age feudalism anarchy
what's its logical conclusion from your
perspective well right-wing libertarian
sort of hard to pin down exactly what it
means to be right-wing libertarian I
mean I think we sort of know it when we
hear it we know it when we see it but I
I do believe that any kind of absolutist
libertarianism is totally unhinged bogus
and barely worth anything beyond just a
thought experiment to say oh here's why
full libertarianism doesn't work and
there is an overlap with sort of extreme
or literal libertarianism and
anarcho-capitalism for sure and it would
have the effect of a feudalist or
totally anarchist system right and the
logical conclusion would be
rampant sort of strongman criminality of
sorts although it might not be
criminality it might not be actual
criminality because in those societies
much of what they would like to do and
what would happen would not actually be
criminal that's sort of part of the
problem right but yeah I think you're I
think Chris there's a really good let me
see here I can find it there was a
really really good thing that you can
check out by googling not seeing it now
they're all wait a second here it is
here it is it's called a non libertarian
FAQ and if you goo let me see what
happens if you google that if it's the
first thing that comes up it's not okay
so that's not a good way to find it you
know what I'm gonna paste this into the
description for this live stream so you
guys can check this out if you're
interested in sort of the debunking of
the simplistic and absolutist
libertarian arguments check out the link
that I just added to the description for
this live stream it is called a non
libertarian FAQ it's kind of long but I
encourage you actually it's not even
that long read through the entire thing
and it'll sort of explain to you just
very basic arguments about why
libertarianism in a lot of ways just
does not work and would not work okay on
that note people saying David is it your
bedtime it's very close to my bedtime
I'm going to wrap up the stream we'll do
another one soon please get those
patreon contributions in sign up for
membership if you value the show if you
really missed us during that two-week
vacation in August that's what it would
be like indefinitely if there was no
show so please contribute and I
appreciate everybody who sent
contributions during the street